A brand-new poster for the upcoming Wonder
Woman 1984 hit the internet earlier this week,
posted to Twitter by none other than director
Patty Jenkins herself.
We can't blame Jenkins for wanting the world
to see the dazzling poster as soon as possible.
In a word, it's retro.
The one-sheet flawlessly captures the aesthetic
of the 1980s, bursting with every shade of
the neon rainbow that all come together to
form a massive W.
But it's much more than just an ultra-cool-looking
piece of promotional material.
This Wonder Woman 1984 poster gives fans their
first look at Diana Prince's brand-new costume,
which looks a whole lot like her Gold Armor
from the DC comics.
In the source material, Diana obtains enhanced
abilities when she dons the glimmering get-up:
she's able to fly; withstand explosions, bullets,
energy blasts, and physical attacks; and can
utilize the retractable faceplate on her helmet
to breathe from a protected air supply if
her oxygen is low or if the air around her
is unclean.
That should come in handy next time she has
to breathe the air in London.
"Welcome to jolly ol' London."
"It's hideous."
"Yeah, it's not for everybody."
In DC Comics canon, the Themysciran artisan
Pallas created the Gold Armor and gifted it
to Diana for use in battles against incredibly
powerful opponents.
It proved its worth in Wonder Woman's fights
against villains like the living weapon Devastation.
Given that Wonder Woman 1984 sees the titular
heroine face off with the Barbara Ann Minerva
iteration of Cheetah, played by Kristen Wiig,
it makes sense why she would need new armor:
she's as formidable a foe as Diana has ever
gone up against before.
A British archaeologist and wealthy heiress,
Barbara transformed into her super-villain
alter-ego after traveling to Africa to visit
a tribe led by a woman with all the force,
strength, and agility of a cheetah.
When marauders kill the woman, a priest named
Chuma carries out the conference of powers
from the slain leader to Barbara.
The ceremony comes with severe consequences,
though, as Barbara doesn't meet all the requirements
to be the perfect host for the Cheetah entity.
As a human, she's overcome with pain; as Cheetah,
she's vicious, vile, and bloodthirsty.
"What do you want, Cheetah?"
"To hurt you, Diana.
What else?"
We don't yet know how Wonder Woman will cross
paths with Cheetah, but once she does, there's
a strong chance that their first fight could
leave the Amazonian warrior shaken.
She might make a quick trip to Themyscira
and seek the aid of Pallas, who could outfit
her with the Gold Armor to help ensure a win
over Cheetah in their next battle.
This isn't the only Wonder Woman 1984 media
that fans got a glimpse of this week.
The Spanish-language fan account DC Universe
shared another one-sheet for the sequel as
displayed at the 2019 Licensing Expo currently
taking place in Las Vegas, Nevada.
Though the Licensing Expo poster is certainly
a visual treat, it doesn't reveal much in
the way of plot.
Warner Bros. and DC Films have stayed incredibly
tight-lipped about the long-awaited Wonder
Woman sequel, revealing very little about
what adventures the eponymous heroine will
embark on for her second turn on the silver
screen.
All we truly know about Wonder Woman 1984
is its time setting, its villain, and that
Pedro Pascal will appear as a mysterious and
yet-unnamed politician character.
Chris Pine will also return as pilot Steve
Trevor…somehow.
As for what the movie will be about, it's
said to follow Diana experiencing conflict
with the Soviet Union during the Cold War
before going head-to-head with Cheetah, but
there's no intel on how everything unfolds.
As backward as it sounds, that shouldn't be
a cause for concern.
Director Jenkins seems to have it all figured
out, telling Deadline in May that there's
a reason why the film takes place in 1984,
which will connect to the sequel's story and
resonate with modern audiences.
Jenkins explained:
With Wonder Woman 1984 nowhere near its June
2020 launch date and the film's promotional
cycle not kicking off until December, fans
sadly must wait a while before they can feast
their eyes on more posters and first-look
footage at the film.
Hopefully the end result is worth the wait.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.